independence square was a rallying point
for young sri lankans on monday and
rally they did
all echoing a common theme
enough is enough
the president and his government must
resign people were afraid earlier but
now i think it's time that we make a
stand and that we stand up for our
rights because this is our sri lanka and
our future protesters had planned a
major show of strength on sunday here at
this monument in colombo built to
celebrate sri lanka's independence from
britain in 1948
but instead their current leaders
imposed a curfew banned any public
gathering and barricaded all roads that
led to independence square
on monday university students added
their voice to the protests we are doing
what we can we are standing we are
standing our ground and we are staying
here to say no you have to go we need a
better country now we are not going to
give in we are not going to be pacified
by this you know minor changes we want
tangible real tangible change we want to
see
everybody step down students from pera
denier university also stepped out a day
earlier refusing to back down when
confronted by police
they fought with police despite a curfew
imposed to limit the unrest
after hours of tense standoff police
used tear gas and water cannon to
disperse
them anger and frustration has mounted
against president gotabe rajapaksa and
his government after the cost of living
skyrocketed and essential items became
scarce
many sri lankans blame what they say is
the administration's mismanagement lack
of planning and corruption for
aggravating economic difficulties sri
lanka shares with many countries around
the world
the government's attempt to restrict
movement through a state of emergency
and a curfew have failed to stop the
protests
the entire cabinet has resigned
allowing the president and his brother
the prime minister to appoint a new
temporary cabinet
the president has now sworn in a
temporary cabinet of four ministers but
protesters say they are not fooled by
such actions
sri lanka is facing multiple crises
there's little or no foreign currency to
buy basic essentials like food medicine
gas and fuel
and now political uncertainty but sri
lankans are taking a stand
miner fernandez al jazeera colombo